are going to begin with some pretty
important weather news for all of you
out there traveling today you may get a
white Christmas but it's not going to be
anything like a dream come true we are
seeing wet dangerous conditions this
morning across the Midwest and the
plains there are bitter temperatures and
blizzard warnings in effect across
multiple States just as millions of
Americans are trying to get home for the
holidays about 3 million people are
booked on around 47 000 scheduled
flights today look it's packed making it
one of the busiest travel days of the
year Chris Van Cleave is at Washington's
Reagan National Airport Chris good
morning to you I see people moving
that's a good sign
well good morning and this is why I
always wish for a warm Christmas this
time of year there are more than 1200
cancellations primarily at two airports
so far today Denver and Chicago those
are big connecting airports Chicago is
going to take the brunt of this and that
means you're going to see cancellations
Ripple across the country this is the
kind of holiday gift Mother Nature is
serving up that no traveler actually
wants for the holidays
sounds good to get stuck in Jamaica but
the bomb Cyclone is blowing up Theo and
Nicole Williams Beach vacation they're
skipping out early to beat the storm
home for Christmas whatever plans we
have we want them to be our plans not
the weather's plans with the airport's
plans
south of the country in the department
of transportation's operations center
secretary Pete butterjudge and his team
are monitoring the potential impacts as
some of the nation's busiest airports
sit in the path of blizzard-like
conditions that's not a great weather
outlook up there no what you're seeing
there is a lot of impacts on some of our
key hubs by early Thursday morning
hundreds of today's flights were already
canceled at Chicago O'Hare this storm
will end up being the storm that steals
Christmas I hope not but look this is
going to affect millions and millions of
Travelers we're also doing what we can
to get the word out about options that
Travelers have to get ahead of the storm
or maybe wait it out and not travel
until its impacts are behind us some 113
million people are expected to travel at
least 50 miles this holiday
as snow and frigid temperatures push
across the country blanketing streets
outside Minneapolis
here in Wyoming state troopers battled
negative 18 degree temperatures and zero
visibility responding to more than 100
crashes in Georgia it's bracing for a
rare hard freeze as Arkansas plans to
treat roads ahead of possible wintry mix
in the Deep South The most important
thing is to be safe and that might mean
taking a little time or delaying a plan
as the temperatures plummet the roads
we'll likely be treacherous across much
of this country the airlines think
they'll be able to at least operate some
flights out of Chicago O'Hare until
about midday when the weather will
really deteriorate there one good thing
the airline says they saw a real spike
in people taking advantage of all those
travel waivers to move their flights so
hopefully fewer people will be impacted
as the cancellations Mount throughout
the day today Nate
The Good the Bad the Ugly of holiday
travel Chris thank you